Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritla und äh heute.
Zehnte Juli zwanzig einundzwanzig und ähm leider etwas
früher als erhofft und angekündigt, schieben wir hier ein äh Corona-Weekli wieder ein, denn wir wollten uns ja mal kurz melden, wenn sich mal wieder was tut, was es vielleicht zu besprechen gilt. Wir, das sind natürlich neben meiner Wenigkeit, vor allem der Pavel, Pavel Meyer, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja genau und sollte irgendjemand hier noch reinschalten der vielleicht unser Programm bisher noch nicht so richtig gehört hat. An dieser Stelle mal eine
Erläuterung nochmal was wir machen ist seit Beginn
dieser Pandemie in irgendeiner Form das verfügbare Zahlenmaterial und sonstige Meldungen zu durchforsten und mal so schauen, wie so die Debatten laufen und so unseren eigenen Reim drauf machen und für euch so ein bisschen das Ganze vorzukauen, damit der ganze Mist überhaupt
noch zu konsumieren ist. Ja und genau das machen wir jetzt auch. Ich bin eigentlich gerade so äh zwischen dem Urlaub
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie's dir geht, aber ich habe so die erste Urlaubsphase jetzt gerade hinter mir. Bin jetzt zufällig mal ein, zwei Tage zwischendurch nochmal in Berlin und werde dann wieder weiterziehen.
Ähm bei dir hast du die Stadt überhaupt schon verlassen.
Ja, ich habe äh eine kleine äh Wochenendtour mit dem Motorrad nach Hamburg gemacht.
Sehr schön. Genau, man muss ja die niedrigen Inziden nutzen, wie,
wie sie kommen. Wer weiß, wann wir das wieder haben werden.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal gleich äh zum Kern der ganzen Sache, warum wir beide irgendwie dachten, jetzt muss man vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen äh die Situation analysieren. Wir hatten jetzt
längere Phase von, ich weiß gar nicht, zwei Monaten stimmt das? Äh.
Ja kommt drauf an, was du jetzt als nächstes sagen willst, wodurch.
Inzidenzen, so. Das wollte ich jetzt sagen, aber ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich jetzt gerade den konkreten Zeitraum gar nicht, äh seit wann es fällt.
Erst seit dem ersten.
Fünften eigentlich, Moment, nee, das sind die Zahl der Todesfälle. Oh, ja, das fällt jetzt schon, ja, lange. Müsste ich gleich nochmal gucken.
Ja, genau.
War ähm.
Solange äh findet das alles ähm statt und.
Auch ganz gut aus, war auch, also ich habe so ein bisschen drauf gehofft, dass wir zumindest auf die Zahlen kommen,
die wir so nach der ersten Welle gesehen haben. Die sind natürlich so ein bisschen weil ne, Test-Regime und so weiter, das war ja so gegen Ende der ersten Welle
so langsam im aber das dauerte dann auch alles noch so ein bisschen bis hoch gefahren wurde, aber es gibt ja diesen schönen Indikator oder Positiv Quote.
Und ich glaube, wir sind nicht ganz da angekommen, wo wir da waren. Ähm,
aber zumindest so halbwegs. So und jetzt gibt's seit einiger Zeit Berichte. Erst ging's los in Großbritannien, schon vor einiger Zeit mit steigenden Zahlen, wegen der Delta-Variante.
Obwohl ja UK mit ihrer Impfvorreihe schon verhältnismäßig weit fortgeschritten war. Ähm und so seit ein paar Wochen,
Rauschen dann die Zahlen auch um uns herum nach oben ähm Holland ist dazu.
Zu melden und was jetzt grade gar nicht wäre in Europa, Spanien hat, glaube ich, auch extrem hohe Zahlen
Portugal war, glaube ich, sogar zuerst betroffen, weil da die britischen Touristen offenbar das als erstes aufgeschlagen sind. Ja.
Griechenland zieht auch an irgendwie Dänemark zieht an Belgien zieht an,
Frankreich zieht leicht an, auch auf hohem Niveau. Schweiz hat auch die Trendwende. Ja, Tschechien ist noch ziemlich weit unten, Italien.
Österreich auch noch und wir sind ganz unten eigens vor Polen nun wieder, aber trotzdem ziemlich. Also wir sind.
Bei uns ist noch am besten so, so Haus ist noch am besten.
Zu Hause am Schönsten, ne? Ja,
Genau, so sieht's aus. Ich mache mir auch gerade mal hier ein Bild mit unseren Nachbarländern, Luxemburg, knallt auch durch, Niederlande, Dänemark, Belgien wieder mal,
Es ist wirklich zum Heulen. Frankreich, Schweiz, Tschechien, Österreich, alle schon wieder in der Inzidenz vor uns und bei uns gibt's,
Tja, was gibt's denn bei uns? Gibt's äh überhaupt was? Erzähl doch mal, wie sieht's denn äh aus? Es zahlen Material, was was liest du daraus?
Ja, also die Trendwende ist da, allerdings noch auf eben sehr, sehr niedrigen Niveau so ähm ja, mit,
Inzidenzen.
Nach wie vor einstellig, so, je nachdem ja, wie man rechnet, sechs Komma sieben äh pro hunderttausend in sieben Tagen.
Nee sechs Komma eins zwei NRW war sechs Komma sieben, sechs Komma eins
so oder nach äh RKI offizielle Inzidenz fünf Komma acht, also irgendwo um die sechs auf hunderttausend äh liegen wir halt Deutschland.
Weit gerade und.
Sind wir gekommen auf fünf, ne?
Ja. Ähm also ja, nicht, ich glaube, nicht ganz unter fünf, wenn ich das ja, ja.
Komma null irgendwas. Das habe ich so in Erinnerung. Das ist jetzt sozusagen so ein bisschen der Turning Point. Wir hatten in der ersten Welle, sind wir aber auf drei runter. Und die Positivrate liegt jetzt, glaube ich, bei null Komma acht Prozent, was ja eigentlich ein sehr guter Wert ist
Da waren wir aber auch, glaube ich, irgendwann mal bei null Komma sieben oder so was angelangt in der ersten Welle.
Also fünf Komma zwei war irgendwie so das Niedrigste jetzt. Ja.
Zwei, okay. Mhm.
Und jetzt sind wir bei fünf acht, also ist jetzt noch nicht, also man kann jetzt noch nicht davon reden, dass äh ja, die Zahlen jetzt hier in die Höhe geschossen äh wären, aber wir haben halt eine klare Trend
Umkehr und wir haben halt vor allen Dingen jetzt,
seit dem einundzwanzigsten Sechsten, also seit drei und drei Wochen steigt halt der RWRt ständig und äh,
ja, ist halt jetzt seit ein paar Tagen äh über eins gestiegen
so und das ist halt ein Zustand, so den will man eigentlich nicht haben. Ähm aber wie gesagt, zum Glück.
Noch auf niedrigen Niveau und der R-Wert sieht eben,
auch noch nicht so gewaltig aus. Äh also mit eins Komma null sieben. Ähm.
Ja äh hält sich der eben auch noch in Grenzen. So, aber wir weben aus anderen Ländern gesehen haben, kann sich das.
Halt ganz schnell umdrehen und es sieht auch noch nicht so aus, als wenn der Anstieg des R-Werts sich jetzt stabilisiert hätte, das heißt äh nicht nur, dass wir
sowieso einen exponentiellen Anstieg haben, aber der Exponent,
steigt sozusagen, gerade auch noch so, also haben jetzt gewissermaßen eine überexponentielle Entwicklung.
Ja. Oder ja, auf jeden Fall ähm.
Grad nicht so aus, als ob das jetzt nur so ein kurzes aufblitzen in den Zahlen wäre. Ich glaube, wir haben vor zwei Wochen oder vor einer Woche hatte ich, glaube ich, dich mal so gefragt, wie du das so einschätzt. Da meintest du so, hm ja
man noch nicht sagen, aber jetzt kann man's sagen.
Aber jetzt kann man zumindest sagen, ja, äh dass das jetzt äh die Trend,
Umkehr ist und zwar die Trendumkehr hin jetzt zu steigenden Zahlen. Aber, wie gesagt, zu langsam steigenden Zahlen von einem noch relativ niedrigen Niveau,
aus.
Ja gut, aber wenn man sich die Niederlande anschaut, also da ist ja jetzt quasi.
Ähm ich weiß gerade nicht, die sind jetzt hier bei, was weiß ich, einer Inzidenz, vielleicht schon bei hundertfünfzig oder so was angelangt, rechne ich das gerade richtig hier aus den Zahlen raus. Und äh.
Gut, die sind jetzt auch nicht ganz so
tief gekommen, wie wie wir, also das ist natürlich auch nochmal so ein Indikator, also wir haben uns in gewisser Hinsicht schon was Ordentliches erarbeitet wieder, ja, das ist ja wie im Letzten,
im Prinzip auch, also äh es könnte, noch könnte eigentlich alles gut werden, wenn.
Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie keine Lockerungen einleiten würden, wenn wir keinen Wahlkampf hätten.
Den Leuten irgendwie Fröhlichkeit verspricht, dann könnte alles gut werden.
Eigentlich müssten wir jetzt äh so eine Woche Lockdown äh machen. So.
Viel Spaß bei der Diskussion.
Kleinen Zwischen-Lockdown, ja, das wäre das, was wir jetzt eigentlich bräuchten. Also, wenn wir jetzt eine Woche Lockdown machen, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich drei oder vier Wochen äh länger Ruhe.
Ja, so dass wir jetzt der Deal. So, jetzt eine Woche dicht machen und dafür halt äh ja äh drei oder vier Wochen länger äh,
Ruhe haben.
Das ist aber noch wenig. Das ist, glaube ich, zu wenig.
Irgendjemand zu überzeugen. Also das ist jetzt.
Na ja, das da dafür sind's dann halt äh hinterher äh auch natürlich äh drei oder vier Wochen Lockdown, wenn denn dann ein Lockdown kommen sollte, aber gut, ob ein Lockdown,
so ja.
Beide, es wird kein Lockdown kommen bis zur Wahl.
Ja und die Frage ist, ob überhaupt.
Ob überhaupt jemals noch einer kommt, weil er jetzt dann angeblich alle geimpft sind und äh ja, die Krankenhäuser nicht mehr drohen, überlastet zu werden.
Genau, lasst uns über die Konsequenz vielleicht gleich nochmal sprechen, wenn wir auch die Impfquoten durchhaben, äh vielleicht nochmal so einen Blick auch äh darauf, wie sich das so in den Ländern präsentiert.
Ja, also mal vielleicht erstmal einen Blick noch auf die ähm.
Ja, auf die äh wie sich das in den verschiedenen Altersgruppen äh entwickelt. So und
ja, dass es halt sehr erfreulich bei äh deutschlandweit, so bei den über Achtzigjährigen und auch bei den über ähm so Sechzigjährigen eigentlich Inzidenzen von eins Komma irgendwas
hunderttausend so eins Komma drei. Ähm ja, bis.
Eins Komma neun. Hm und die höchsten Inzidenzen und das ist auch da, wo eigentlich grade der Anstieg stattfindet, ist bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig jährigen, ja.
Wie zu erwarten so da ist wahrscheinlich die Impfquote sehr, sehr gering in der Altersgruppe
und äh die haben halt mal einfach dann jetzt aber auch die Fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen und die ja, ganz kleinen äh auch überholt,
so. Die sind erfreulicherweise, also ja, die die fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen auch nur bei sechs, äh bei einer Inzidenz von sechs auf hundert, tausend, sechs Komma fünf,
Und wie gesagt, dann die ähm eben.
Fünfzehn bis Vierunddreißigjährigen liegen dann bei dreizehn mittlerweile wieder Inzidenz. Das heißt, in der Gruppe ist es quasi außer Kontrolle.
Welche Gruppe ist es außer Kontrolle? Fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig.
Dreißig, ja.
Der Rest liegt so mit dem R bei eins oder kurz da drunter. Das aber auch das sind alles steigende stark steigende Zahlen, also das.
Ja, also der R-Wert steigt, äh sagen, in allen Altersgruppen an und mittlerweile, ja.
Eben.
Außer achtzig Plus.
Nee, aber auch äh also äh achtzig plus und interessanterweise fünf bis vierzehn und hm.
Und null bis vier. In den Altersgruppen äh liegt
der der quasi R Wert noch unter eins in den anderen Altersgruppen irgendwie über eins mittlerweile. Also sehr verworrenes Bild.
Grade, was die Altersgruppen angeht.
Was können wir daraus lesen? Also die, die jetzt im Wesentlichen Urlaub machen, die sind auch alle.
Ja
Ganz gut dabei, irgendwas zu verbreiten.
Ich glaube, es ist mal wieder das Partyvolk. Äh.
Das darf ja noch gar nicht. Aber demnächst dann.
Ja ja ich meine die Leute, die jetzt die Lokale bevölkern äh so.
Ja, verstehe.
Und Bars und weiß ich nicht.
Ja klar, die halt auch alle irgendwie ihren äh ihr Leben wieder haben wollen. Das kann ich ja auch alles gut verstehen und die sich aber natürlich jetzt wieder so von diesen Botschaften mit jetzt sind die Inzidenzen niedrig, dann so hurra, dann stürzen wir uns doch mal gleich rein.
Und die alle nicht wahrscheinlich fast alle nicht geimpft sind.
Schwierig zu sagen. Leider, da komme ich gleich drauf zu, haben wir da überhaupt gar keine detaillierten Informationen.
Bundesländer.
Ja. Ja. Bundesländer ähm liegen halt auch.
Ja, was heißt eng beieinander? So, wenn man ähm auf die rein Inzidenzen äh guckt.
Haben wir ja so quasi paradiesische Zustände noch, na ja, ja, Brandenburg mit einer Inzidenz.
Von äh drei äh so drei Komma eins und dann Sachsen äh Anhalt
eins Komma sieben und Sachsen zwei Komma drei und Thüringen zwei Komma null und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern eins Komma zwei, also das sind so alles äh Jahr zwischen eins und
äh vier, sage ich mal, äh Schleswig-Holstein ist auch noch, ist gerade bei vier oder bei drei Komma neun.
Also der Osten ist gerade sehr gut und ähm der hohe Norden auch und so ab Niedersachsen wird's dann langsam geht's dann langsam hoch.
Ja, müsste dann durchschnittlich und aktuell ist Bremen und das Saarland.
Mit äh recht hohen Inziden und Hamburg auch, aber dafür noch mit einem R von null Komma neun neun,
Ja und Berlin ist auch so eher in der im oberen Drittel.
Leider vertreten und auch mit einem recht hohen Rwert äh leider.
Und wenn man jetzt guckt.
Falls der so jetzt bleiben sollte, was äh wie gesagt nicht zu erwarten ist, äh.
So ist, ist es halt grade ja,
in vielen Ländern, in vier Wochen wäre es dann immer noch okay. So ähm,
Und das würde wahrscheinlich also in den nächsten vier Wochen werden halt keinerlei Maßnahmen dann zu erwarten
aber ähm ja, in einigen Ländern und in Berlin, wer dann aber spätestens in ähm ja, anderthalb Monaten,
oder so äh werden wir dann wieder über fünfzig, ja, in,
Also äh und dann würden wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwie zumindest Dinge passieren. Gehe ich mal davon aus. So und selbst wenn keine Dinge passieren müssen, müsste man dann wieder anfangen, noch mehr aufzupassen.
Hm? So, also dann wär's zumindest nicht mehr so relativ entspannt, wie es jetzt ist.
Also das Geschehen ist sehr unterschiedlich. Ich meine, deine Tabelle rechnet ja die Inzidenz, ähm auf Basis der publizierten Fälle, so für die nächsten vier und acht Wochen aus.
Warum hast du das eigentlich bei den Meldedaten nicht auch auf acht Wochen, nur auf vier Wochen?
Wegen Spaltenanzahl.
Okay gut das das Rennen hast du schon vor längerer Zeit verloren, aber okay, nur mal so als Orientierung, also würde es in Bremen jetzt so weitergehen wie jetzt,
Ja und die Tendenz zeigt ja nochmal nach oben. Dann werden acht Wochen, wenn wir schon wieder bei hundertdreiunddreißiger Inzidenzoo und Saarland bei neunundsechzig und Berlin bei dreiundsiebzig, also das ist halt einfach alles nicht gut.
Äh
Halt das Ding, ne? Und die Tendenz ist halt nicht abzusehen, vor allem ist halt schwierig, aber reden wir gleich nochmal drüber, so dieses so, was was soll das jetzt noch bremsen, ne?
Ja. Also grob kann man sagen so ja die nächsten vier Wochen äh.
Sind wahrscheinlich noch okay. Äh so und für die.
Vier Wochen danach äh ist es nicht mehr überall okay.
So würde ich äh dass die Situation mal charakterisieren. Das, was ich erwarte und mit.
Okay äh äh meine ich halt, ich sage mal unter fünfzig,
was nicht wirklich okay ist, aber so äh angesichts jetzt Impfungen und so weiter äh also ist zumindest dann,
ja, keinen Zusammenbruch des Gesundheitssystems und keine Welle von Toten zumindest zu erwarten, bis dahin, sodass wieder.
Genau, wie sieht's denn mit den sterbenden aus?
Weil das war ja nun immer das Ding, dass eigentlich die Todeszahlen, so die Inzidenzen gefolgt sind, wir können jetzt aber wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, zumindest zeichnet sich das in anderen Ländern so ab.
Diese direkte Verbindung durch die Impferei getrennt worden ist.
Ja. Nee, definitiv. Äh also ich habe dann hier auch mal äh die Fallsterblichkeit äh mal geplottet so in äh verschiedenen,
Gruppen, also beziehungsweise vor allem in den hohen Altersgruppen, so bei äh ja sechzig, neunundsiebzig und achtzig Plus. Und äh ja
da
ist, also bei achtzig Plus ist äh mittlerweile die Fallsterblichkeit von hm ungefähr zwanzig Prozent
auf äh ja, zwei Prozent in der Gegend, drei Prozent, sowas äh runtergegangen.
Mhm.
Und äh ja, für sechzig bis neunundsiebzig auch von irgendwo sechs Prozent auf praktisch,
null Prozent oder null Komma äh es ist null Komma null null acht Prozent, also ich sage mal,
so wie es aussieht im Moment, also in der letzten Woche sind halt vermutlich fast nur über achtzig Jährige gestorben und davon auch eben nur.
Ja, wenige so.
Zwei, drei Prozent der Infizierten. Mhm. Okay.
So, also insofern äh kann man sagen, was die Fallsterblichkeit
angeht, äh sieht es so aus, als wenn die Impfungen genau das tun, äh was sie versprechen, nämlich äh ja äh Menschen äh das Leben zu retten.
Dann rutten wir doch mal den Zahlenchor so ab mit den äh Testzahlen.
Ja. Ähm die haben sich auch äh nach unten,
entwickelt, ähm jetzt sowohl was die Anzahl der Tests angeht, aber auch die Anzahl der positiven,
Tests und äh dementsprechend dann auch sind wir jetzt beinahe positiven Quote von null Komma acht Prozent angekommen. In der Sechsundzwanzigsten Kalenderwoche.
Die bis zum vierten siebten lief. Ja und es gibt aber immer noch, also es wurden immer noch.
Um die fast siebenhunderttausend Leute getestet, das heißt.
Kann man dann auch, wenn man einen Vergleich ziehen mit,
wie vor einem Jahr. Im August hatten wir ungefähr so Testzahlen, die sich,
in der äh Gegend bewegen und hatten damals auch so Quoten, also ja knapp unter ein Prozent um die ein Prozent
Und das beste, was wir, glaube ich mal hatten, waren richtig sehen, null Komma sechs zwei,
noch jemand weniger zu bieten, ne, null Komma sechs zwei war irgendwie die niedrigste positiven Quote.
Genau vor einem Jahr übrigens.
Und fast genau vor einem Jahr her in der ja in der siebenundzwanzigsten Kalenderwoche letzten Jahres äh hatten wir an den Tiefpunkt erreicht. Und dann ging's ein bisschen höher.
So wie jetzt auch, allerdings ging's dann danach im August ähm.
Dann aber noch mal wieder runter, weil dann die Zahl der Tests auch ausgeweitet wurde, aber trotzdem ja.
Gegen dann die positiven Quote auf jeden Fall nochmal runter, aber eigentlich gingen dann die Zahlen im letzten Jahr ja, sie absoluten positiv getesteten.
Ging dann eigentlich ab der vierundzwanzigsten. Nee, habt ihr ja.
Auch ob wir so ungefähr ab dieser Woche ungefähr Pfingsten anzusteigen und ging dann nicht mehr wirklich runter.
Äh Korrektur übrigens, der niedrigste Wert von null Komma fünf neun tatsächlich in der KW achtundzwanzig, also wirklich exakt genau vor einem Jahr.
Also wir haben jetzt exakt nach einem Jahr, wo wir so ein Tal durchschritten haben, ähm.
Nee, sechsundzwanzig haben wir jetzt, aber äh ja, also in zwei Wochen wär's dann.
KW aber Moment ja bis zum zwölften siebten, also ja gut die verschieben sich immer. Also nächste Woche.
Ja, okay. Im Wesentlichen ist es dieselbe Zeit.
Ja. Gut, gucken wir mal, wie es so läuft. Ähm.
Nix dagegen, wenn sich zumindest den Sommer über was tut, aber wir haben natürlich etwas andere Voraussetzungen. Letztes Jahr hatten wir es zu diesem Zeitpunkt einfach ausschließlich mit dem Wildtyp zu tun.
Der sich eben durch die Maßnahmen dann doch relativ gut eindämmen ließ und jetzt haben wir natürlich mit der Deltavariante eine etwas andere Situation. Aber da gucken wir dann äh auch gleich nochmal dazu.
Ja ja.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal auf die Impfsituation.
Das ist wirklich ein großes Seufz. Ich ähm verfolge das so ein bisschen.
Und wir haben jetzt seit ungefähr einem Monat.
Fallende.
Impfzahl. Also wir hatten so ein totale O's irgendwie. Es gab mal so im Schnitt, also ich berechne immer diesen sieben Tage Schnitt, also quasi wie viele
Impfung gab es pro Tag im Schnitt, wenn man eine Woche äh rückwärts berücksichtigt und der
Impfaktivste Tag war halt so Mitte Juni, wo wir dann irgendwie auf achthundertfünfzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag gekommen sind.
Mittlerweile seit gestern äh ist das auf sechshundertdreiunddreißigtausend gefallen und die Tendenz zeigt grade nach unten,
Und das ist insofern etwas verstörend, als dass wir noch nie so viel Impfstoff hatten.
Also es ist einfach kein Mangel da und trotzdem gehen die Impfzahlen nach unten.
Ja
und dem Lichter äh ist es halt auch so, dass das immer noch mehr Zweitimpfungen vorgenommen werden als Erstimpfung, also da fehlt einfach grade so ein bisschen der Druck der Leute, die sich überhaupt das erste Mal impfen lassen,
das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein.
Rätsel. Viele Leute lassen ihre Termine sausen, also man hört so aus den Impfzentren. Von Praxen habe ich jetzt so nix gehört, aber das mag da ähnlich sein, dass so fünf bis zehn Prozent.
Einfach ihre Termine nicht wahrnehmen und die dann halt auch nicht absagen. Ja, also das das ist ja nochmal.
Hm.
Ein extra Problem. Das heißt, die Impfzentren stellen sich auf einen bestimmten Andrang ein. Der kommt dann nicht oder zumindest nicht in dem Maße. Das kriegen die irgendwie derzeit. Also.
Gut, ich kenne jetzt.
Ich habe so ein paar genauere Einblicke so in die Situation in ein Impfzentrum. Berlin und nochmal so einen sekundären Einblick in die Situation in Hamburg. Da gibt's dann immer schon Unterschiede, aber was halt so generell
gesagt wird, ist immer, wir könnten eigentlich alle viel mehr.
Also jetzt von der reinen Personalleistung, von der Kapazität des Ortes hätte man schon immer mehr impfen können. Na, ich glaube, die Arena, die ist bestenfalls so zu fünfzig Prozent ausgelastet gewesen.
Vergleich zu dem, was da aufgebaut wurde und was man theoretisch stemmen könnte.
Und jetzt kommt halt einfach nur mal dazu, dass die Leute halt einfach mit Beginn der Sommerferien hier in Berlin irgendwie ja ihre Termine einfach nicht wahrgenommen haben, was natürlich mal ein doppeltes Problem ist, weil andere Leute warten auf Termine, kriegen keine.
Die, die abgemacht sind, die werden dann halt nicht ähm realisiert so und,
absagen, wer dann zumindest es ist zwar immer noch doof, aber das gibt zumindest die Möglichkeit, bei den Terminen das zu machen. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer die Schuld der Leute, weil es natürlich auch oft so ist
Wir haben ja sehr unterschiedliche Terminmeldesysteme, die auch unterschiedlich gut verstanden werden. Es war schon sehr schwierig für ältere Leute, sich überhaupt Termine zu klicken. Bei
absagen, ist es dann halt nochmal komplizierter, entweder gibt's diese Möglichkeit gar nicht oder die sind sowohl verborgenen, komplizierten User-Interfaces oder die Leute haben halt telefonisch irgendwas
kommen und wüssten gar nicht, wo sie dann anrufen sollen und rufen vielleicht irgendwo an, aber dann wird es nie storniert. Also das ist,
Diese ganze Terminplanung ist schon immer ein Elend gewesen und es nicht besser geworden seitdem.
Wir sind, es wird richtig, wir sind jetzt runter irgendwie.
Fast zweihunderttausend äh Impfungen pro Tag äh nur noch, also Erstimpfungen, ja,
und das aber im Prinzip also unter dreihunderttausend,
sind wir jetzt seit sechs Wochen oder so, seit sechs Wochen kommt gar nicht mehr so viel dazu, jeden Tag, also.
Während äh.
Seit zwei Monaten gelingt es uns nicht mehr als dreihunderttausend äh Erstimpfungen pro Tag durchzuführen. Und wir waren da schon mal bei sechshunderttausend. Klar, das war natürlich jetzt primär in dieser Zeit einfach
hing es einfach an der Verfügbarkeit des Impfstoffs. Es gab dann verschiedene Probleme. Das hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung auch nochmal anklingen lassen. Dass einfach Biotich ähm.
Nicht wie es weiter steigern konnte, moderner äh gab's dann Ausfälle und Verzögerungen ist generell immer schwierig, wie viel kam. Johnson Johnson spielt im ganzen Geschehen ohnehin nur eine sehr,
kleine Rolle und ähm das hat natürlich die Planbarkeit äh immer erschwert. Mittlerweile
Ist es aber so, dass wir einfach genug Impfstoff da haben. So und insbesondere bei Astra Seneka geht es halt irgendwie alles nicht so richtig weg.
Das hat verschiedene Gründe und hm nicht alles lässt sich aus diesem Zahlenmaterial gut erklären.
Was ähm
offensichtlich ist es äh schon seit längerem, dass es einfach logistisch schwierig ist oder was heißt logistisch oder für die Ärzte generell schwierig ist, den Leuten irgendwie Asra zu,
verabreichen. Dann hat sich ja jetzt die Empfehlung auch geändert bezüglich dieser Kombiimpfung. Es gab ja schon seit längerem diese Ansage ja die, die ähm
geimpft wurden und die eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr in die Empfehlung fallen, also jünger als sechzig sind, dass die halt äh mit biotech geimpft werden sollen.
Trotzdem gab's noch mal so ein leichtes Aufflammen von Asra Senica, Zweitimpfungen in den letzten Wochen, wo ich mir gefragt habe, wo die jetzt eigentlich herkommen und dann ähm wurde jetzt nochmal eine komplette
andere Ansage gemacht und man hat halt jetzt empfohlen, generell auf Kreuzimpfungen zu gehen
was an sich eine super Idee ist und ich glaube, wir hatten das hier auch schon mal angedeutet.
Ja. Wir hatten nicht nur angedeutet, dass das ähm eine gute Idee zu sein scheint, sondern glaube ich auch vorhergesagt, dass die Skikur das irgendwann empfehlen wird. Ähm.
Ja, nur nur ist halt diese Empfehlung so ein bisschen ungenügend, weil durch diese Beschränkung auf Ü sechzig, ja und es gibt ja einfach jetzt einfach,
zunehmendem Maße immer weniger Leute, die über sechzig sind und noch keine Erstimpfung haben, ja? Ähm.
Eher ja ist es natürlich, es ist natürlich super kompliziert, wobei wenn man das möchte. So, kann man
sich halt äh ja diese äh Kreuzimpfung jetzt besorgen, weil du äh klar die Empfehlung ist zwar über sechzig, aber du kannst halt auch unter sechzig auf Wunsch äh dich mit Astra impfen.
Lassen ähm und äh ja äh also im im Prinzip.
Auf Wunsch äh kann man diese Kreuzimpfung kriegen äh so, aber sie entspricht in der Tat dann
nicht hundertprozentig der Empfehlung, wobei in dem Moment, wo man erst äh Astra sich geholt hat, äh so, dann äh ist wiederum, dann ist man empfehlungskonform,
den Moment, ja.
Ja, also das ist ein großes Durcheinander und klar kann man Ausnahmen und so, aber dann hängt es halt immer wieder sehr von den Ärzten ab, wie sehr die das unterstützen und da höre ich sehr unterschiedliche Sachen.
Mir.
Machen sie nicht und äh ja.
Ja
Das auch nicht vor.
Ja von Sturen, Bayerischen Ärzten, habe ich da gehört, aber in einem Fall, dass da jetzt nichts
lässt sich vielleicht nicht äh wirklich verallgemeinern. Äh auf der anderen Seite habe ich mit einer Ärztin gesprochen, die das Testing gemacht hat auf einer Veranstaltung
wo ich war, beziehungsweise bei Dreherarbeiten, bei denen ich war und äh ja, die hatte sich selbst äh auch die Kreuzimpfung äh besorgt für sich
weil sie meinte, also
Das sei halt das Beste so. Das das war dann wiederum so ein bisschen so eine Bestätigung, wenn du dann einen Arzt triffst, der dann auch in dem Bereich arbeitet und sich das dann
selber auch. So äh.
Und was jetzt bei dieser Impfung ja auch noch gefallen ist, ist diese zeitliche Beschränkung. Also bisher war ja das Regime erste Mal Asra, Sineka und dann musst du aber drei Monate warten, bis du irgendwie dann deine.
Oder mindestens neun Wochen und mittlerweile sieht's so aus
Wenn man sich jetzt mit Asra Senica äh erst geimpft hat, kann man nach vier Wochen im Prinzip schon mit Bier und Tisch oder moderner nachgeimpft werden,
Und das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen der Rostlöser. Und allen Leuten, die jetzt noch überhaupt gar keine Erstimpfung haben, ja, und die jetzt nicht unbedingt in diesen kritischen Bereich fallen, so wie.
Weiß ich, zwanzigjährige, junge Frau, ja, sondern wo es einfach.
Ich sage mal so, ab ist immer schwierig jetzt, solche Erfüllungen zu geben, ja, aber äh ich habe Asra Senica gehabt, ich bin irgendwie Mitte fünfzig, ich habe da nicht auch nur eine Sekunde drüber nachgedacht so, ja und äh äh
sicherlich diese diese Entscheidung auch gefällt, wenn ich irgendwie noch zehn Jahre jünger wäre. Ähm man kann also es gibt,
Wege, ja, es hängt immer so ein bisschen davon ab, es ist schwierig, deine Empfehlung zu geben, weil Impfzentren ham's dann teilweise nicht, Ärzte haben's
dann teilweise erste bestellen jetzt auch kein Astra Senica mehr. All so eine Sachen, also die Verfügbarkeit ist mir grade noch unklar, aber wenn man die Möglichkeit hat
impfen lassen und vier Wochen später irgendwie moderner oder Biotisch hinterher und dann hat man einfach den umfassendsten Impfschutz nachdem wie die Studien derzeit so ausfallen und das sagt ja auch die STIKO und ähm.
Spürbar mehr Resistenz quasi oder potenzielle Resistenz gegen diese Varianten, die jetzt grade unterwegs sind.
Also bei Risiken so in Größenordnung von, ich sage mal, eins zu hunderttausend bis eins zu einer Millionen oder so
da denke ich nicht lange drüber nach. Ich meine jedes Mal, wenn ich's aufs aufs Motorrad steige, setze ich mich irgendwie ein Risiko in dieser Größenordnung aus irgendwie
Verletzungen oder Schäden oder Tod davon zu tragen, weil ja äh also insofern äh ja.
Im selben Bereich, ne.
In der selben Größenordnung und insofern aber klar, man muss natürlich keine überflüssigen Risiken ähm eingehen, wenn's Alternativen gibt, die.
Ja, besser oder sicherer sind äh und genau das Gleiche äh bewirken. Ähm,
aber ich fand halt einfach die äh die Studienergebnisse einfach ganz interessant und überzeugend und äh ja.
Vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen das Zahlenmaterial hier bei den äh im Verein nochmal. Ähm was was wir so für Quoten jetzt eigentlich erreicht haben.
Also die offizielle Zahl, Erstimpfung liegt bei achtundfünfzig Komma zwei Prozent, vollständig geimpft, zweiundvierzig Komma eins Prozent.
Der Unterschied der schmilzt natürlich, weil immer noch mehr Zweitimpfungen ausgegeben werden als Erstimpfung zunehmend.
Ähm klingt jetzt auch erstmal nicht schlecht, ja. Ist aber so ein bisschen,
ungefähr die Hälfte von dem, was ich gerne sehen würde. Ähm ich habe aber auch mal ausgerechnet, dass twitter ich ja auch immer mit,
ähm wie groß der Prozentanteil eigentlich unter denen ist, die sich technisch überhaupt impfen lassen könnten, also,
ja derzeit da die Situation Impfung nur für zwölf plus. Da ist also erst geimpft fünfundsechzig Komma vier Prozent und äh vollständig geimpft siebenundvierzig Komma
drei Prozent, also da nähern wir uns schon so zwei Drittel, die tatsächlich äh sich hätten impfen lassen können, haben diesen Prozess auch begonnen und ähm,
fast die Hälfte von denen, die äh überhaupt eine Impfung erhalten können.
Haben sie auch jetzt schon vollständig erhalten und werden in zwei Wochen dann entsprechenden vollständigen Impfschutz offiziell haben.
Das ist so eine Zahl, die selten reflektiert wird. Wir haben eine relativ alte Bevölkerung, deswegen.
Glaube ich auch, dass wir schneller jetzt so an Israels Zahlen zum Beispiel rankommen,
Einfach weil mehr Alte dabei sind, so. Israel, da hatten wir ja auch äh hier mal, ne, so, oh Gott, bei sechzig Prozent ist Schluss und was ist denn da los? Was wir dann gemerkt haben, na ja.
Die bis Zwölfjährigen, die machen äh oder bis Sechzehnjährigen in dem Fall, machen halt irgendwie auch dreißig Prozent äh der Bevölkerung aus. Also da ist da gar nicht mehr so sehr viel Spiel gewesen.
Ähm das Impfstatistische Tweetamt einer dieser schönen äh
Twitter-Accounts, die ähm sich auch auf die Impfzahlen stürzen und die tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr Number Crunching machen als ich. Ich äh hole mir immer nur die Zahlen für fünfte,
porten, ballert die hier irgendwie in meine äh mein rein und da äh habe ich dann so eine gewisse Tiefe nicht. Also ich untersuche das nicht nochmal nach Bundesländern, ich untersuche das auch nicht nach
weiteren ähm Lieferdetails, wohin wurde geliefert und so weiter. Also meine Auswertung ist, ich würde nicht sagen, oberflächlich, aber nicht so tief, wie sie äh theoretisch die Daten
wie die Daten das erlauben. Ähm wenn man halt da äh äh sich richtig in die Excel-Dateien rantraut, dann kriegt man mittlerweile auch die
Auswertung nach.
Und das ist halt äh leider in Deutschland aus Gründen, die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann, aber das ist nun mal die Situation, werden nur drei Altersgruppen unterschieden in Deutschland beim Impfen, bei der Meldung, nämlich.
Über sechzig, über achtzehn und unter achtzehn. Das ist alles. Und das ist wirklich ein bisschen mau, ne.
Mhm.
Aber gucken wir doch mal, äh das bedeutet, wir haben derzeit ungefähr vierundachtzig Prozent der Leute über sechzig haben mindestens eine Impfung.
So bei vierundachtzig Prozent der über Sechzigjährigen. Ähm.
Achtzehn bis neunundfünfzig.
Sind wir ungefähr bei sechsundfünfzig Prozent.
Sechsundfünfzig Prozent haben mindestens eine Impfung in Deutschland achtzehn bis neunundfünfzig Jahre.
Und bei den Unter Achtzehnjährigen.
Äh liegt die Zahl ungefähr bei zwölf Prozent. Was ich schon mal ganz gut finde eigentlich.
Nichts gegen noch höhere Zahlen, aber ja, da tut sich was. Die Impfung von jüngeren,
scheint aber auch noch mal so ein kleines Desaster für sich zu sein, weil ja hier die STIKO-Empfehlung,
Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal besprochen. Ein bisschen.
Also zwar nachvollziehbar ist, ja, ich sie mir aber auch anders wünschen würde. Die Perspektive der Stiko ist halt.
Ist es schon vollkommen auszuschließen, dass die Impfung Kindern schadet. Das ist so deren Perspektive. Das ist so.
Wie das Deko argumentiert und sie sagen halt so, na ja, das Datenmaterial, was uns vorliegt und was wir ausgewertet haben, reicht noch nicht aus. Ich weiß nicht, auf wie viel Datenmaterial sie dann noch warten, aber
offensichtlich gibt's da noch keine Bewegung in diesem Bereich, die zu einer Überarbeitung dieser Position führen könnte.
Mittlerweile wird ja in den USA, in Israel, werden ja auch sehr viele äh geimpft, aber offensichtlich gibt's hier noch keine belastbaren
Zahlen und ich hoffe, dass die auch bald rauskommen. Und dazu sagen sie ja, okay, alles klar, ist zwar zugelassen, aber empfehlen tun wir es halt nur für Kinder mit Vorerkrankungen.
Die dann offensichtlich äh hoffentlich das bekommen. Jetzt ist die Frage, wo werden die geimpft? Es gibt Impfzentren, die impfen irgendwie gar nicht äh unter,
teilweise auch unter Achtzehnjährige, nicht teilweise unter Sechzehnjährige nicht und halt äh eben so zwölf plus. Da muss man dann eben auch richtig suchen. Ähm da habe ich jetzt nur ein sehr.
Oberflächliches Bild, wie sich das so in den einzelnen Bundesländern darstellt, will da jetzt gar keine Aussagen zu tätigen, dafür ist das alles nur so anekdotischer Kram, den ich auf Twitter äh höre, aber ja, das ist ähm.
Ist so ein bisschen die Situation und in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass wir jetzt steigende Inzidenzen haben, dass so ab.
Anfang August zumindest in ein paar Bundesländern der Schulbetrieb dann wieder losgeht, beziehungsweise ja derzeit glaube ich die noch nicht mal überall angefangen haben.
Also wir haben auch Schulbetrieb haben, heißt das, äh das äh noch für ein paar Monate, ähm ja, die Kinder auch durchaus noch bedroht sind und es mehren sich die Berichte, dass ähm
ist kein Anlass,
das auf die leichte Schulter zu nehmen, dass Kinder sehr wohl betroffen sein können, halt nicht so primär wie die Alten mit besonders schweren Verläufen und ähm.
Sondern eben eher so sekundäre Effekte, also eine Infektion, dass äh bestimmte Symptome eben auch einfach noch lange halten und das ist halt auch nix, was man will.
Also ich hatte zufällig vor zwei Tagen habe ich mich mit einem äh Freund getroffen. Ähm
der jetzt so sich also vor der Frage stand, ist der jetzt irgendwie seinen fünfzehn Jährigen
Sohn impfen oder nicht äh so und er war eher erstmal nie äh halt auch
Befürchtung von Langzeitwirkungen. Das ist, das scheint immer so die,
genau die größte Befürchtung zu sein. Und ich habe,
dann auch nochmal versucht, gut, was wenn ich in derselben Situation wäre? Ich meine, halb
irgendwie, ich habe eine fünfundzwanzigjährige Tochter äh so, äh wo ich auch eher entweder zur Impfung äh raten oder davon abraten soll. Ich habe ja eigentlich dazu geraten
das zu tun und zwar ich mein.
Lang, Langzeit äh Wirkungen. Ja, man kann sich auf der einen Seite auf äh die Position stellen, ja, so eine
Impfung ist halt ein dauerhafter Eingriff ins Immunsystem und verändert äh das Immunsystem und wir verstehen das alles noch nicht vollständig, äh was da genau vor sich geht
und äh ja. So, das ist nur sagen die, die eine äh Sicht äh der Dinge. Ähm.
Die andere Sicht ist so, das ist eher meine Gut, was was passiert denn da eigentlich äh nach der Impfung? So, der Körper fängt an ähm erstmal,
vor allem neutralisierende Antikörper äh zu bilden. So äh Plus eben dann äh Teegedächtnis zählen und äh äh B-Zellen im Wesentlichen.
Die neutralisierenden Antikörper, die nehmen im Laufe der Zeit einfach ab,
und äh ja, genauso ist es eigentlich mit äh all den anderen Dingen, die so die Impfung hervorruft, die das geht dann
nach der Impfung steigen, ich sage mal, die die Werte von Körpern oder die, die,
das Ergebnis der Reaktion auf die Impfung steigt halt erstmal an so über mehrere Wochen, aber irgendwann
ist es halt auf Maximum angekommen und dann geht halt alles wieder nach unten, dann verlieren wir leider fast alle unsere neutralisierenden Antikörper so nach äh sechs Monaten oder so und es bleiben halt
dann die Gedächtniszellen, äh so die es die dann helfen eben äh ja dann im Falle einer Infektion die schnellere Immunantwort zu
organisieren. Aber mein eigentlicher Punkt war.
Ich sage mal, alles, was nicht innerhalb von sechs bis also sagen wir drei Monaten
so würde ich sagen. Alles, was nicht innerhalb von drei Monaten passiert, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, aus meiner Sicht, dass äh
sagen dann noch nach Jahren oder so andere Dinge passieren, ausschließen,
so zu hundert Prozent kann man das nicht, aber das äh ja, müsste dann schon mit dem Teufel zugehen, zumal,
was dann auch noch dazu kommt, ist, dass halt jetzt diese Impfungen schon millionenfach durchgeführt worden sind, auch bei Kindern und äh Jugendlichen und
ja wenn man auch so viele Leute impft, dann trifft natürlich dieser Impfstoff auch auf die unterschiedlichsten ähm
ja Organismen oder unterschiedlich veranlagten
Personen und da ist jetzt auch nicht allzu viel bekannt geworden, dass da jetzt plötzlich durch die Impfung größere Schäden passiert sind. So, aber Restrisiko,
bleibt halt äh immer in irgendeiner Größenordnung so. Das ist sagen die Impfung.
Auf der anderen Seite jetzt bei Delta, wenn das jetzt losläuft ähm bleibt vermutlich für jeden, auch für die Jugendlichen oder für die Kinder nur die Alternative auf lange Sicht Infektion.
Oder Impfung, ja? Und wenn ich mir dann das nehme, was halt äh.
Von der Infektion äh bekannt ist. Da es ja, die meisten Kinder stecken äh diese Infektionen,
recht gut weg so und dann gewisser Anteil halt nicht so gut, so,
Ordnung zehn Prozent äh haben halt schon einen eher unangenehmen Verlauf, ja, also wo man das halt dem Kind nicht wünscht. Äh.
Und die bei denen ist das halt ja durchaus wie eine schwere Grippe mit Fieber und Husten und allem und dann eben äh ja
'ne hartnäckige Form davon, die dann wiederum bei einem paar Prozent äh über Wochen oder Monate,
so und da ist natürlich über die Langzeitwirkungen einer Covid-Infektion,
auch nichts bekannt, ja. So muss man sagen, vor allen Dingen die neuen Varianten äh und so. Und wenn ich dann die beiden Risiken einfach äh,
nebeneinander halte, also wenn auf lange Sicht,
im Wesentlichen die Entscheidung zwischen Impfung oder Infektion besteht, dann ja, würde ich auf jeden Fall zur Impfung raten oder mich für die Impfung
entscheiden, äh wenn das, egal in welchem Alter, so, sobald das irgendwie möglich ist, ähm.
Im Moment allerdings
weil den aktuellen niedrigen Inzidenzen besteht vielleicht noch nicht so der grade der der Superdruck, das unbedingt jetzt morgen äh zu machen
Aber so im Hinblick auf den Herbst oder den Winter äh denke ich, äh sollte man sich dann auch nicht allzu viel äh Zeit lassen. Ich denke auch, dass das genau passieren wird,
dass die Empfehlung durchaus auch was damit zu tun hat
das natürlich abgewogen äh werden muss zwischen, also bei Impfstoffverfügbarkeit oder abgewogen werden musste und es in der Tat
nicht sinnvoll gewesen wäre, Kinder zu impfen, solange äh noch bei äh ja älteren und,
Erwachsenen äh für die noch nicht genug Impfstoff da ist, so das wäre wirklich kontraproduktiv gewesen.
Es gibt ja, muss man auch sagen, es gibt ja die
Impfempfehlung für Kinder in Situationen, wo die zum Beispiel in einem Haushalt leben, wo entweder eine schwangere Mutter da ist oder die nicht geimpft ist oder irgendwie jemand, der
aus anderen gesundheitlichen Gründen für eine Impfung nicht in Frage kommt.
In solchen Fällen wird halt dann auch die Impfung für Kinder ja ausdrücklich empfohlen, ja. So, also von daher kann's jetzt äh ist das Risiko auch aus Sicht der ähm.
Äh ständigen Impfkommission
äh durch die Impfung äh schätzt die das nicht so groß ein, äh dass es ethisch bedenklich wäre, äh sagen Kinder dieser Gefahr auszusetzen, nur um jetzt Erwachsene zu schützen.
Sondern so groß ist die Gefahr dann äh offensichtlich doch nicht, als dass man das den Kindern nicht zumuten könnte zum Schutz der Erwachsenen äh sich impfen zu.
Genau und das Argument, dass jetzt kein das äh Impfstoff weggenommen wird, das zählt halt jetzt gerade nicht. Also,
sind wir jetzt einfach nicht mehr und von daher kann man das jetzt einfach mal rausnehmen aus dieser Gleichung. Vielleicht noch mal so für euch da draußen auch äh zur Orientierung. Also ich habe zwei Kinder.
Eins ist jetzt gerade vierzehn geworden. Das ist jetzt schon einmal geimpft worden und äh.
Das andere kriecht sozusagen zum zwölften Geburtstag, dass die Info zum zum Geburtstag. So und die und die haben auch selber ähm.
Beziehen die da auch Position. So, der Große meint er halt so, waschen, so eher so empört irgendwie über die Schwierigkeiten, sich impfen zu lassen als Kind so, meinte so, äh was.
Was ich weiß immer ganz genau, die Formulierung war, aber es ging so in die Richtung mit ich ich möchte doch gerne in die Lage versetzt werden, meine Großeltern zu schützen.
Weißt du, also äh.
Glaube, man kann sich auch bisschen mal trennen von diesem, man muss irgendwie alle mentalen äh Entscheidungen für die Kinder äh da treffen, so äh die haben auch eine Position und auch eine
Sicht auf das geschehen und und spüren da auch Verantwortung und das ist halt auch Teil äh Teil des Spiels.
Ja und ab vierzehn ist noch offiziell religionsmündig äh so. Also ich finde äh,
da kann man dann auch äh ja, wenn Impfung zur Glaubensfrage äh wird, äh so müssten die.
Kinder da dann eigentlich ab vierzehn äh eigentlich auch frei drüber entscheiden dürfen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Oder.
Gut, lass uns dann mal so ein bisschen die Situation bewerten und die Bewertung der Situation hat eben viel mit Delta zu tun. Delta ist mittlerweile das dominante.
Die dominante Variante auch in Deutschland, die letzten offiziellen Zahlen, die immer ein bisschen hinterher hinken, sind äh gelten für die KW.
KW fünfundzwanzig und wir sind jetzt glaube ich schon KW siebenundzwanzig,
jetzt geradeaus, genau. Ähm K wie fünfundzwanzig, also vor zwei Wochen
der Anteil von Delta in Deutschland neunundfünfzig Prozent und wenn ich Herrn Drosten in seinem Podcast richtig verstanden habe, kann man
diesen Zahlen auch. Wir glauben schenken, weil bei den niedrigen Inzedenzen wird mittlerweile so viel sequenziert, im Anteil, dass man da also da sich relativ äh im Klaren ist. Interessant ist.
Dass Delta jetzt Alpha komplett verdrängt, aber Beta und Garma, also die Südafrika und die Brasilienvariante spielen nach wie vor keine nennenswerte Rolle. Die haben da einfach überhaupt keine Chance.
Gegen anzukommen. Was bedeutet das jetzt für uns?
Ist schwierig, also in Großbritannien hat sich äh Delta der Bevölkerung gut annehmen können, obwohl da viel geimpft wurde,
das Impfbesteck ist da etwas anders gelagert, dadurch dass halt ähm sehr viel mehr Astrasinika verabreicht wurde.
Aber auch in Israel gibt es äh Steigenzahlen, also auch da, wo nur Biotech ähm unterwegs ist, kann das eine Rolle haben. Ist allerdings auch so,
natürlich die Geschwindigkeit der Impfvorreihe sehr unterschiedlich war in Israel besonders stark und dass das auch so ein bisschen,
einen Unterschied macht.
Ich kann da auch nochmal in was verlinken, ich krieg das jetzt im Detail allerdings auswendig nicht mehr so richtig runtergebetet warum, wie, was, wo, aber im Kern
macht es einfach einen Unterschied, ob man eben sehr schnell impft in die Bevölkerung und jetzt ist das sozusagen alles schon wieder eine Weile her, weil ja dann eben auch so die
Antikörper, die eben sich unmittelbar
bilden, so insbesondere das IGA, äh die Körper, die direkt im Rachen liegen, sich natürlich dann nach einer bestimmten Zeit ähm anders ausbreiten.
Also da du hast einfach eine andere Mischung in der Bevölkerung, je nachdem, ob da einmal schon alles durchgeimpft wurde in kurzer Zeit oder ob das so ein kontinuierliche Geschichte ist, ähm bewirkt es dann eben, dass.
Verschiedene Varianten, unterschiedliche Angriffspunkte haben und deswegen sind.
Die Zahlen nicht so ohne Weiteres vergleichbar, darauf wollte ich ihn eigentlich hinaus. Und auch in Deutschland haben wir ein anderes Geschehen, wir haben ein anderes Altersgeschehen, wir haben eine andere Verteilung.
Wir haben die alten schon relativ gut geimpft. Es ist überhaupt eine Zahl, die vorhin durchgekommen ist. Wir haben bei Ü sechzig vierundachtzig Prozent. Das ist eigentlich eine sehr gute Zahl.
Das ist äh deutlich mehr, als ich äh erwartet hätte
und ähm gut, da mögen auch noch ein paar Ungenauigkeiten drinstecken, aber jetzt auch nicht so viel Ungenauigkeiten, dass die Zahl jetzt überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig wäre, wenn wir das halt irgendwie äh auch sonst noch so hinbekommen würden, wäre das ja schon mal sehr gut, ne,
Also ja, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was ich draus machen soll, aber wir dürfen das jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht auf die leichte Schulter nehmen.
Ich denke, politisch, das hatten wir am Anfang schon mal anklingen lassen.
Es gibt einfach derzeit keinen politischen Debattenraum für irgendwelche Lockdowns.
Werden weniger Tote sehen, dadurch dass die Impfung da sind, das heißt, wir sehen zwar eine Infektionsgeschehen, aber wir werden halt nicht so.
Sterben sehen und wir werden auch nicht in dem selben Maße eine Überlastung der Intensivstationen sehen. Das ist zumindest meine Erwartung.
Die Diskussion wird über Inzidenzen laufen und dann wird.
Nochmal ein anderer Faktor draufgeschlagen, so nach dem Motto, na ja, Inzidenz hundert von heute ist ja nicht, was Inzidenz hundert vor, vor einem halben Jahr war. Und.
Stück weit stimmt es auch. Ja, es hat einen anderen Impact auf die Gesellschaft. Die Frage ist nur, was was wollen wir denn weiterhin,
laufen lassen und wie viel Risiko jetzt auch noch eine deutsche Variante mit in den Pool zu geben, wollen wir denn jetzt hier.
Überhaupt zulassen.
Mhm. Ja. Ich meine, das Problem ist, wenn man sich dann fragt, okay, wie viele.
Menschen können sich denn jetzt durch das Virus eigentlich noch infizieren in der Bevölkerung, dann,
muss man halt, ja, also die Rechnung ist dann halt nicht, nicht ganz einfach, aber
Ähm man muss dann gucken, ähm eigentlich wie viele Personen haben denn jetzt,
sagen bereits oder noch einen ausreichenden Impfschutz
so, weil wir ja schon mehrfach gesagt haben, jetzt um sich um Ansteckung zu verhindern und Weitergabe zu verhindern, kommt's halt vor allem auf die neutralisierenden Antikörper an und da weiß man
auch, dass äh zumindest ältere Personen, ich glaube über siebzig gab's da eine Studie, die
äh hatte festgestellt, dass bei dreißig Prozent der über siebzigjährigen keine neutralisierenden Antikörper nachweisbar waren in dieser Studie
sagen, nach der, also,
nach der Zweitimpfung, also man hat dann nach jeder, nach der ersten und zweiten Dosis immer im Wochenabstand die Antikörper gemessen und äh ja. Ähm.
Gut, positiv ist, siebzig Prozent hatten nachweisbare äh Antikörper, aber sagen den Teil muss man dann quasi auch noch,
potenziell abziehen plus diejenigen, bei denen die Impfung dann zu lange zurückliegt,
so und das heißt äh muss man auch mal ein Modell machen, wenn denn dann klar ist, äh wie
lange, also wenn man ein vernünftiges Modell hat, wie denn die Antikörper dann abnehmen, kann man dann quasi sowas wie den Immunstatus der Bevölkerung ähm.
Sehen und der äh nimmt dann irgendwann eben auch einfach wieder ab. Ähm so,
und dann wissen wir halt auch, dass äh mittlerweile leider dann äh eben der der Schutz äh dann äh bei Impfung der ist zwar sehr hoch, aber eben dann doch nicht absolut.
So und es gibt eben dann auch vor allem bei älteren, auch wenn sie geimpft sind, kann es dann auch zu äh schweren Verläufen,
kommen.
Plus. Dann haben wir eben noch die ganzen Ungeimpften jüngeren Leute, sodass wir faktisch äh ja, wenn man sagen für das aus Sicht des Virus jetzt.
Steht halt noch über die Hälfte der Bevölkerung als wird bereit und zur Verfügung.
Und ähm sprich, wenn wir jetzt dann sagen, naja gut, jetzt lassen wir das halt mit den Maßnahmen und lassen dem Virus einfach mal freien Lauf oder die Leute sollen sich halt,
selber schützen äh einfach. Äh dann sind halt ja fünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung äh wenn die sich innerhalb von.
Zwei, drei Monaten eher von zwei Monaten plötzlich durchinfizieren
das wird dann auch 'nen sehr traumatisches Ereignis werden noch trotz Impfstoffen weil man dann natürlich plötzlich auch sehr sehr viele jüngere Leute äh einfach sie wird mit.
Schweren Verläufen.
So, ja, weil wir dann plötzlich äh möglicherweise mehr Infektionen äh kriegen innerhalb von zwei Monaten, als äh in der gesamten Pandemie bisher.
Ja
und das bleibt dann selbst wenn die meisten Alten eben geschützt sind, also wir sind jetzt runter auf äh ungefähr bei den Infizierten ähm.
Auf,
in den älteren Alters über alle Altersgruppen sind wir unter was waren das? Null Komma zwei Prozent oder so jetzt bei der.
Sterblichkeit, ja,
Also bei den Alten waren wir auf zwei Komma vier Prozent äh runter, also bei den über Achtzigjährigen. Aktuell.
Und äh ja,
ähm aber wir werden dann immer noch äh werden dann immer vermutlich so dann im null Komma,
irgendwas Prozentbereich dann trotzdem noch Menschen haben, äh die dann versterben und ähm so, selbst wenn's dann nur null Komma ein Prozent
sind, äh aber du plötzlich nochmal zehn oder zwanzig Millionen Infizierte hast, äh so, das ist dann auch unerträglich.
Ja
Na gut, ich meine, was die Gesellschaft als erträglich ansehen wird, das äh ist, glaube ich, dann auch nochmal ein dehnbarer Begriff. Das Ding ist nur, man kann natürlich jetzt zur aktuellen Situation.
Von dem ausgehen, was jetzt gerade ist so, ne? Aber der griechische Alphabet hat noch eine ganze Menge Buchstaben.
Wir sind jetzt irgendwie an Platz vier. Äh ich glaube, vergeben für Varianten auf Konzern, ist sogar schon Lamm da. Also es geht schon so ein bisschen in die Zukunft, nur spielen die bisher noch keine Rolle. Ähm,
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir nicht morgen schon wieder es mit einer neuen Variante zu tun haben, die äh noch irgendeine andere kritische Komponente wieder aufmacht,
Immerhin haben wir es mit verhältnismäßig gut wirkenden Impfstoffen zu tun in Deutschland, muss man dazu sagen, in China,
Impfstoffe haben keinen.
Rekord, also äh Länder wie Chile et cetera, wo sehr hohe Impfraten äh erzielt wurden mit äh chinesischen Impfstoffen war dann die Infektionsrate, ging dann doch wieder durch die Decke,
extrem. Ähm von daher müssen wir wahrscheinlich auch erst äh ja, MR und A für alle,
bevor wir das dann eben auch global in den Griff kriegen. So und wenn wir wirklich daran arbeiten wollen, diese ganze Pandemie an sich in den Griff zu bekommen in überschaubaren Zeitraum
sind noch sehr viel mehr Anstrengungen erforderlich und diese Anstrengung finde ich, kann man halt auch in Deutschland machen. Also ich bin definitiv dagegen ähm.
So was wie in jetzt in in in Holland oder in äh Großbritannien mit irgendwie ja keine Maskenpflicht mehr in,
Räumen oder so, Supermärkten oder Nahverkehr oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist einfach oder Schulen. Das ist einfach ähm unverantwortlich. Also dadurch.
Treiben wir es einfach äh unnötig hoch, obwohl wir es schon so gut erlernt haben und nicht so viel dadurch verhindert wird. Ich kann trotzdem noch einen Supermarkt geben, auch mit Maske.
Ja? Also ja, also ich ich werde mich auch äh egal, ob erforderlich oder nicht, äh
Ähm also ich handhabe das im Moment äh so, dass überall äh wo ich irgendwie unter fremden bin in Innenräumen, ich nach wie vor halt auch eine Maske äh aufsetze und äh.
Die nur abnehme, irgendwie okay, draußen oder äh wenn's halt eine Gruppe von getesteten Leuten äh.
So, ja, das ist 'ne trügerische Sicherheit, weiß ich, aber die Inzidenzen sind auch niedrig im Moment.
Insofern, ja.
Bin ich da jetzt auch nicht der super paranoide, übervorsichtige, muss ich sagen, gut. Äh vielleicht auch äh sag mal dadurch, dass ich jetzt eben auch geimpft bin und äh ja.
Impfung eigentlich jetzt auch ihre volle Wirkung äh gerade entfalten müsste, so,
zusammen genommen, ja, denke ich, ist das für mich zumindest akzeptabel.
Und.
Ja, der also die Sache ist halt halt einfach die ähm wenn man jetzt strikt nach,
vorgehen würde, wie man sagen Handbuch effektive Pandemiebekämpfung äh sage ich mal, äh dann äh lockert kann man halt nur lockern, wenn,
noch stabil und deutlich unter eins liegt. Ja und also über eins,
dass halt keine Lockerungsperspektive, ne. So,
sondern im Gegenteil, in dem Moment, ich meine, man kann ein bisschen Schwankungen zulassen, sagen wir mal, bis zehn oder fünfzehn, aber eigentlich müsste man spätestens, wenn man die zehn oder fünfzehn
äh pro hunderttausend überschreitet ist dann äh dann sofort äh mit einer Woche Lockdown äh reingehen. Dann kann man wahrscheinlich wieder äh äh auf,
zwei Wochen.
So würde so könnten wir wahrscheinlich, also mit dem Regime könnten wir ähm wahrscheinlich locker bis in den November oder Dezember irgendwie uns niedrige Inzidenzen nennen,
erhalten, wenn wir das machen mit ab und zu mal eine Woche oder zwei halt ein bisschen äh das Land anhalten,
ähm ja und ihr habt jetzt von vielen Leuten im Übrigen auch gehört, dass sie eigentlich äh so durchaus auch gewisse Aspekte jetzt dieser Pandemie genossen haben, so.
Also insbesondere gewisse Entschleunigung auch und,
Manche Leute, die auch nicht so extrovertiert sind, fanden halt das auch ganz gut, dass sie jetzt nicht so oft ausgehen müssen und sich mit irgendwie anderen Leuten treffen müssen und so, also ja.
Ja, also für das autistische Spektrum, weil er sicherlich einiges dabei, aber
Wird sich halt auch einfach nicht durchhalten lassen, ne. Jetzt haben wir die Situation, jetzt ist halt viel Urlaub, äh ist ein bisschen schwierig, wie sich das jetzt so entwickeln wird. Ich finde halt so die Steigerung in den Niederlanden und so und.
Finde ich alles sehr bedenklich. Wir werden Rückreiseverkehr haben, wir werden sehr viel Einschleppungen haben aus diesen ganzen aus dieser Urlaubstätigkeit und ich habe nicht so den Eindruck,
dass wir irgendwie gut vorbereitet sind oder es auch nur der Wille besteht jetzt im Herbst irgendwas nennenswert besser zu machen. Also es ist einfach.
Bin da etwas pessimistisch geworden, was so die Response der Gesellschaft betrifft, insbesondere unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass wir eben diese Wahl haben und niemand jetzt vor der Wahl irgendwie mit.
Wir müssen jetzt härter gegen die Pandemie vorgehen. Äh äh auf eine Bühne steigen möchte.
Gibt's jetzt noch irgendwas, was wir noch besprechen müssen Pavillon? Was hast du noch für erwähnenswert hältst.
Mir ist nur heute aufgefallen, dass irgendwie das Hashtag Laschet Welle gerade am trennen äh war. Ähm so weil,
äh ja, weil äh dort äh jetzt endgültig gelockert äh werden soll, so Texas-Style in NRW und äh während,
in den Niederlanden grade wieder die Maßnahmen hochgefahren werden, weil die Zahlen da regelrecht explodiert sind
und die Leute jetzt sagen, äh ja, der Typ ist doch irre äh so äh das wird uns noch teuer zu stehen äh kommen.
Man wird sehen äh ich meine im Moment steht NRW noch nicht ganz
äh so schlimm da, die sind eigentlich so im Mittelfeld, aber äh ja
steigen auf, wenn wir dann sehen, dann vielleicht nächste Sendung in, weiß ich nicht, drei, vier Wochen oder so
das auf jeden Fall weiterverfolgen wie das Experiment Nordrhein-Westfalen denn dann so gelaufen sein wird.
Wir dann die Laschet Welle bekommen haben.
Genau, also irgendwie, genau, also wir,
jetzt nicht ähm nächste Woche nicht gleich wieder in den nächsten äh Aufschlag machen, aber äh wenn sich sozusagen nennenswert, was was tut und abzeichnet, dann dann kommen wir ja auf jeden Fall wieder zusammen. Ansonsten wollte ich eigentlich jetzt nochmal so ein bisschen
äh entspannen. Mich in den niedrigen Inziden bräunen.
Also in den nächsten vier Wochen sollte das äh eigentlich auch noch fast überall in Deutschland möglich sein. Ähm ja,
in in dem für den Monat drauf gebe ich jetzt keine Garantien
ab äh so, also insofern sollte man jetzt vielleicht Dinge nicht auf die lange Bank äh schieben im Moment, insbesondere, was jetzt so das Reisen angeht.
Oder das Impfen. Also wir empfehlen euch, äh euch einfach äh dringend ähm euch um Impftermine äh zu kümmern und auch äh.
Für eure Kinderschar mit dazu. So ist denn äh möglich ist und ähm.
Da abgewiesen werdet, äh einfach nochmal woanders probieren. Also mittlerweile gibt's genug Impfstoff, das ist jetzt echt nicht mehr das Problem. Gut.
Dann sagen wir ähm vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei unserer kleinen Sonderausgabe zwischendurch. Und ähm habt noch einen schönen Urlaub, wenn oder falls falls ihr schon mittendrin seid oder demnächst.
Antretet oder was auch immer eure Sommerbeschäftigung sein sollte. Ja und wir melden uns wieder, wenn's was Neues gibt.